All right, animation retargeting.
Let's get started.
So retargeting, it allows animations to be reused between characters with the same skeleton
and they could have vastly different proportions.
Now Unreal, it uses a concept called a rig, which I would have called bone mapping, and
it acts as the translator from one character to another.
The character's proportions may be different, but the skeletons need to be similar enough
to be mapped to the same bone mapping.
And what I mean by that is no inserted or missing bones in the middle of the chain.
I mean you could have a winged angel character and, you know, if the angel has a similar
skeletal structure to a human that you already have in the level, except the only difference
is it has wings, that is fine.
You would not be able to retarget motion from a biped character to say a cat that walks
on all fours.
But you could retarget from a quadruped to another quadruped.
And I also want to mention the concept of the bind pose.
And just for now, I want you to know that if the original pose of your character is
different than the one that you are retargeting to, it will affect the fidelity of the animation.
And there's ways to work around that, but keep that in mind when you are retargeting.
Okay, so I want us to go ahead and dive into Unreal.
So I'm here in the engine, and what you can do to follow along is go to File, New Project,
select the Games Template, hit Next, and grab the Third Person Template.
It's got some good animations for this demo.
Hit Next.
Find a good folder path for your project.
I called this project Retargeting Crowds.
You can call it whatever you like.
Hit Create Project.
I will close the dialog window because I already have a project.
And then the next thing I would like you to do is go to your Epic Games launcher and select
the Marketplace tab.
And then in the Search Products section, type in Infinity Blade.
Now we're looking for the Infinity Blade Warriors pack.
And these characters were designed specifically for the skeleton that isn't Unreal, so this
is perfect for a retargeting example.
Now I already own this pack, so you might have a different button right here.
Go ahead and click on that, but then you'll have the option to add to project.
And then it says, no compatible projects.
It's actually okay.
There's no blueprint functionality that would clash with code or anything like that.
So just select Show All Projects.
Grab your project.
And I know the red letters look a little scary.
It's okay.
Just select 4.26, Add to Project, and I promise it will actually be okay.
And we'll let that come in.
So I'm back in the engine.
I'm going to click the Show or Hide Sources panel.
And then on the left, you'll notice we now have an Infinity Blade Warriors folder.
And next up, we will talk about the Retarget Manager.